you know there's a a real problem in
this country
uh where whereby
people will abort babies on the basis
of what they consider to be uh defects
this is specifically true of babies with
down syndrome
and it's disgusting but it happens all
over the
all over the place you will you'll go in
i mean when you're
about to have a baby you go into the
doctor they say okay we're gonna do a
screening you know
and uh you know then we're gonna we're
gonna figure out if you know if they
have down syndrome or something like
that
then we can discuss our options what
options what do you mean options
oh the option is do you have the baby or
do you kill the baby do you kill the
baby because you don't think he's
perfect
because he's got down syndrome where
he's got some other condition
that's the real thinking that goes on
and it's led to extraordinarily high
rates
of abortion of killing down syndrome
babies
and some countries boast about it you
know in iceland a few years ago there
was a big press release they said
iceland has eradicated down syndrome
as if they cured a disease but there's
no cure for down syndrome it's not like
they
figured out some kind of gene therapy
that would fix
down syndrome they just kill them all
how ghastly is that and the left
cheering this on yes we kill babies
because
they have intellectual deficiencies
aren't we wonderful well uh governor
christie gnome in south dakota has just
uh just come out against this process
she says children with down syndrome are
a gift to us all i'm asking the south
dakota legislature to pass a law that
bans the abortion of a pre-born child
just because that child is diagnosed
with down syndrome we must stand for the
right to life of every preborn child
absolutely right stuff and a good way by
the way
to to go after this issue you know there
what conservatives really want to do is
get rid of legal abortion
and some sometimes conservatives are
honest about that
i try to be honest about that uh
sometimes conservatives make these
really frivolous arguments where they
say you know abortion
we want to get rid of abortion because
it's bad for the mother
or it's it's harmful we want to protect
mothers and you know what i mean
psychologically spiritually i guess
that's true
but no you want to protect the baby
that's being killed they'll say we you
know
we want to uh we want to only have safe
abortions and that's why
we're going to shut down the abortion
clinics because they're not safe well no
it's no abortion is safe it kills a baby
obviously that's not
you know they're all kind of somewhat
disingenuous arguments but they're
tactical and they think it's going to
chip away at the edges here and they're
fine by me this is a good way to do it
this is actually a good way to do it
because you are appealing
to the moral standard that the left at
least pretends to have namely
that they oppose racism or sexism or
ableism ableism being
discrimination and bigotry against
people with handicaps
what if what if we passed a law and said
you can't
abort a baby just because he's black do
you think the left would object to that
i'm sure they'd find some way to object
to that but it'd be very difficult for
them to
what if we had a lot said you can't you
can't abort a baby just because she's a
girl
and that sort of thing does happen not
maybe not so much in the united states
yet but
certainly around the world i mean we saw
that happen in china which is why
there's a lopsided population now
people were choosing boys and then
aborting the girls
what if we passed a law like christinom
says to
ban abortions of babies just because
they have intellectual deficiencies
i'm sure the left would find a way to
argue against it but it would be very
very difficult argument it would make
them look very very ugly i think it
would
move the needle and as as christina has
this kind of
solid spine and i think real evidence of
political acumen
she is positioning herself very well for
2024 which a lot of people have been
talking about
you know i'm noticing there have been
some people coming out there was
actually a very prominent professor who
came out against christinom
who said christinom you're your state
has one of the highest
levels of kovid and kovid death and
covet hospitalization
in the country that's true it's up in
like the top five or top ten or
something
it's way below new york though and you
know you know andy cuomo
is being hailed by all of the left
christina put herself in a very very
good position and seems to have
a lot of moral clarity i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show to check out the full
episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you